il est promis n'a appelé papa plus tard
c'est dangereux
et a foutu tu as perdu une place
d'un bâton si la responsabilité je te
rappelle
juste en trois secondes est une donnée
nouvelle fois
pour son premier vendée globe la course
autour du monde en solitaire yann
kermadec remplace au pied levé
francoville et au troisième jour il est
tout simplement second au classement
général
[ __ ] de merde
comment tu es monté qu'est-ce que vous
là haut
tout ça c'est ma course c'est quoi cette
route a time merde avant tout va bien si
jamais on voit je suis mort
tu gardes confiance si tu continues
d'accord
à
mais franck t'inquiète je sais ce que je
fais ici ce qui fait débat direct sur la
plage au brésil je me suis bien ou pas
un contre que tu vas ma soeur mais on
prend pas pour un con moi la vérité
yan yan
tu mentalement tout est fini
j'ai pas tout [ __ ] en l'air que si tu
arrives
pour moi tu peux gagner